eigentlich galt der vulkan ball
schahrudi nahen osten russlands als
längst erloschen doch offensichtlich
nimmt seine aktivität wieder zu und
fachleuten zufolge könnte sie derzeit zu
einem ausbruch kommen und das hätte
fatale folgen und zwar nicht nur für
russland sondern die ganze erde doch die
genaue untersuchung des lokals gestaltet
sich als äußerst kompliziert wie hoch
ist also die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es
wirklich zu einem ausbruch kommt und
welche folgen hätte es für den rest der
welt krieg zum science fiction irgendwas
täglich faszinierendes science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
und vielen dank für den themenvorschlag
von jan dennis schulte der über
telegramm reinkam den link zu unserer
telegramm community findet ihr in der
video beschreibung oder am ende des
videos der vulkanwolke janina gehört zu
der vulkan gruppe klubchefs kaya und
liegt auf der pazifik halbinsel
kamtschatka im osten von russland die
insel ist 450 kilometer breit und 1200
kilometer lang und wirklich nicht ohne
sie gehört zum weltnaturerbe und zählt
unglaubliche 160 vulkane allein im 20
kilometer weiten umkreis von goldscheuer
yahoo den komoren zehn vulkane drei von
ihnen sind laut experten und expertinnen
aktiv doch besondere sorge bereitet den
fachleuten der 2009 120 meter hohe
vulkan namens ball china eigentlich
gehen wir davon aus dass er erloschen
ist doch schon seit zwei jahren konnten
immer wieder seismische aktivitäten
registriert werden dazu der vulkanologe
ivan kulakow es kann jederzeit zu einem
ausbruch kommen seiner ansicht nach
gegen große gefahr von diesen vulkan aus
da er lange zeit inaktiv war so könne
man vor allem mit einer sehr starken und
exklusiven eruptionen rechnen der grund
anders als bei aktiven vulkanen kann
sich die energie bei in aktiven vulkanen
im inneren ansammeln und das wird laut
dem experten zu einer katastrophalen
eruption mit fatalen folgen natürlich
zum einen für die menschen dieser region
glücklicherweise ist das gebiet in
dieser vulkanlandschaft kaum besiedelt
folgen hätte der ausbruch des vulkans
und die ausgestoßene asche wolken
dagegen vielleicht sogar für das
weltklima zu den ausgestoßenen partikel
sagt iwan cola kopf wenn sie in die
stratosphäre gelangt
könnten die partikel sehr schnell in
einen anderen teil der welt gelangen und
das klima verändern denn die
aschepartikel absorbieren die
sonneneinstrahlung und mindern diese die
erdoberfläche würde sich dann genauso
wie die sogenannte troposphäre abkühlen
damit ist die unterste schicht der
erdatmosphäre gemeint die
darüberliegende stratosphäre also quasi
das zweite stockwerk der erdatmosphäre
in einer höhe von etwa 12 bis 50
kilometern
dagegen würde sich durch die
aschepartikel erwärmen doch nicht nur
das auch für den weltweiten flugverkehr
hätte der ausbruch von goldscheuer oder
unangenehme folgen schlimmer war sogar
als der ausbruch des isländischen
vulkans eyjafjallajökull im jahr 2010
die vulkanasche sorgte damals dafür dass
in weiten teilen nord und mitteleuropas
der flugverkehr lahmgelegt war für
mehrere tage das engagiere saßen fest
und kamen nicht weiter das alles hatte
erhebliche nachteile für die wirtschaft
betroffen waren aber auch beispielsweise
die isländischen bauern deren felder in
vulkanen nicht mehr nutzbar waren
hinzu kommt außerdem noch die gefahr
dass die asche die turbinen der
flugzeuge verstopft manko lag auf hatte
zusammen mit einem internationalen
forschungsteam den vulkan wolf ja und
ina und die region drumherum genauer
untersucht laut der aktuellen studie
konnten dort von mai bis juli 2018
alleine 559 erdbeben registriert werden
im februar 2009 10 fand sogar ein
erdbeben der stärke 4,3 stadt diese
erkenntnisse zeigen nach ansicht der
experten und expertinnen dass der vulkan
nicht länger als erloschen eingestuft
werden kann dennoch sei es unmöglich
eine genaue vorhersage zu der weiteren
entwicklung zu geben die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass der vulkan
ausbricht liegt laut kohler kopf bei
etwa 30 prozent falls dies tatsächlich
der fall sein sollte würde es die ersten
handfesten anzeichen dafür aber erst
wenige tage davor geben einen ausbruch
den könnte man sieben tage im voraus
vorhersagen das problem vor ort gibt es
kaum messstationen denn die potenzielle
gefahr wurde jetzt erst erkannt um alle
weiteren entwicklungen genau zu
beobachten werden derzeit weitere
messstationen installiert eine
komplizierte angelegenheit denn für
dieses vorhaben existiert keinerlei
infrastruktur straßen und städte gibt es
in der näheren umgebung des vulkans
nicht so dass hubschrauber nötig sind
doch diese sind teuer und zu dem wetter
abhängig also hier geht es übrigens zu
unserer telegramm community wo er nicht
nur die videos vorhersehen können
sondern auch diskutieren und
themenvorschläge machen könnt ja und
katastrophe durch super logan hat die
nasa die lösung anklicken anschauen und
klicks um science-fiction abonnieren
dann bleibt dran